und heute ist unabhängigkeitstag in der
ukraine ein besonderer tag über den
besprechen mit reif ziele sind wir
verbunden oberst ade und militärexperte
schön dass hier bei uns sind positiv
was kann was muss passieren aus ihrer
sicht auch als militärischer sicht damit
dieser krieg endlich ein ende findet
wir müssen nur unsere ziel bildung
deutlich besser werden
deutschland hat sich immer als mitläufer
etabliert strategisches hat sich nicht
wirklich gedanken darum gemacht welchen
nutzen es stiften will und welche kosten
was für uns hat auch für unser land
werden ja gerade von waschlappen wird
nova im und mit allen möglichen guten
ratschlägen bediente die regierung die
aber als nicht verpflichtet die nutzen
zu mehren und schaden abzuwenden hat ihn
strategisch wieder aus deutscher sicht
auch für europa noch im atlantischen
sich genug gedanken gemacht wie das in
der ukraine weiter gehen soll im
augenblick richten sich eigentlich alle
auf einen langen mehrjährigen
zermürbungskrieg ein der natürlich
weiter sheen leid über die ukraine ihre
menschen bringt und die infrastrukturen
zerstört das muss besser werden sie
haben gerade da schon harsche kritik
anklingen lassen jetzt haben ja gerade
den kanzler gehört und seine jubiläums
wortes lava ukraine endet er mit diesen
worten dort es lebe die ukraine für
einige in dem land wird das sehr sehr
seltsam klingen wenn man auf die
deutsche politik der vergangenen sechs
monate zu sprechen kommt
konkretisieren sie nochmal ihre kritik
also was hätte die bundesregierung was
der kanzler ihrer meinung nach in den
letzten sechs monaten besser machen
müssen also nachdem anfangs schock den
ja jeder hatte inklusive
muss man ja damals die genannten sich
zusammennehmen der ukraine bei stehen
dass sie nicht verliert war sicherlich
ein sehr guter anfang wir sind dann aber
im grunde in eine phase des russlands
schwächen hineingekommen das war die
amerikanische strategie der us
verteidigungsminister angekündigt hat
man hat sie dann öffentlich ein bisschen
geschwächt aber man sieht dass ein
gnadenlos durch das heißt untersucht
über einen langen zermürbungskrieg
russland zu sprechen das hat aber folgen
dieser folgen hatte es in villigen keine
ja als direkt betroffener als
angriffsziel leidet in jeglicher
hinsicht menschen die soldaten das land
dann für sich in seinen fähigkeiten der
zukunftsfähigkeit aber auch all die
anderen beteiligten eben inklusive
deutschland und hier muss man eben
darüber nachdenken und zum spielen kommt
was muss ich tun dies muss man auch um
vor dem hintergrund einer welt situation
in der gerade im grunde die großen
kämpfe ausgegrenzt werden wären dann
künftig sozusagen was zu sagen haben
china versucht so ein bisschen die welt
führung von den usa zu vergeben in der
prosperität da geht es auch um unsere
arbeitsplätze um die rentenversicherung
die krankenversicherung in der
prosperität versuchen usa und china uns
abzuhängen und die sollen wir denn der
ukraine helfen wenn es uns selbst nicht
mehr gut geht also muss ich diese ganzen
dinge in einen plan zusammen machen und
nicht hineinstolpern im grunde von einer
problemlösung ein bisschen gas hier
finden dort das ist alles nicht wirklich
zielführend und an der stelle müssen wir
dringend besser werden und umso mehr
weil deutschland ja so groß ist in
europa letztlich auch in der welt das
heißt hier weniger gedanken wir uns
machen will weniger tatkraft können wir
auch in europa erwarten und auch hier
schwächer ist jetzt nicht das
transatlantische bündnis die nato mit
dieser situation hier erwarte ich
dringend hohe rente vorschläge also
konkrete vorschläge einen konkreten plan
reift elitär experte oberster den
herzlichen dank für das gespräch mit
ihnen zu gehen
[Musik]